I called up three vaccine researchers
working on three different types of
vaccines thank you so much for joining
us especially given how busy you must be
right now all right so the traditional
way that vaccines have been made is to
inject either a weakened or dead version
of the virus into the body so the immune
system is prepared to fight the real
thing but many of the kovat 19 vaccines
currently in development are using new
technology hello my name is dr. Peter
Hotez and our team was developing a
recombinant protein next my name is
Joseph Kim IDO vo is working on a DNA
based vaccine for covin 19 my name is
Katherine Johnson and we are working on
mRNA vaccine candidates to protect
against Kovach 19 there are over 30
companies working on different types of
vaccines and these three researchers all
at different stages of the timeline
we're now in the process of preparing
our application to get the green light
to begin clinical trials inovio is
currently conducting a phase 1 studies
for his vaccine we are currently in a
phase 1 to trial in the United States
and in Germany evaluating for vaccine
candidates coronaviruses our RNA viruses
but your vaccine is a DNA vaccine so how
does that work in ovios DNA vaccines
work by injecting snippets of DNA as a
vaccine into the person's skin cells the
DNA once delivered instruct the cells to
manufacture the antigens encoded by the
DNA and then once these antigens are
produced in the body the immune system
of that person reacts to it by
generating strong immune responses
against those
so an antigen is a molecule that's
foreign to your body and can elicit an
immune response DNA and RNA vaccines
instead of giving you the virus they're
giving you some genetic code that your
own cells can use to make a small piece
of the virus and then that's what your
immune system is exposed to and that's
what it knows how to fight the beauty of
this is a safe way to teach the immune
system what the real intruder would look
like so mRNA is coding to make proteins
our cells are loaded up with mRNAs that
are coding for many different proteins
that are required in a human cell to do
what the cell needs to do DNA codes for
RNA RNA contains the instructions to
make proteins and proteins are the basic
building blocks for many parts of our
body so we're taking advantage of this
of making a specific mRNA that now is
not coding for cellular protein but it's
actually coding for a viral protein
compare this to a protein based vaccine
our recombinant protein vaccine contains
pieces of the pathogen that we're hoping
to protect against can you define the
recombinant protein vaccine that your
team is working on
you're basically immunizing with a piece
of the virus and that piece is
genetically engineered into yeast so the
way our vaccine works is we formulate it
with something called alum to make it
more immunogenic and then you inject it
and elicits an immune response
consisting of antibody and also t-cells
and how is a protein vaccine different
to an RNA or a DNA vaccine well a
protein together with the aluminum
what's called adjuvant has the ability
to directly stimulate the production of
antibodies that's in contrast to an RNA
or DNA vaccine whereby the RNA or DNA
has to be taken up by a cell and then
one of your own host cells has to
manufacture parts of the protein and
then presented to the immune
Spahn so it's two or three degrees of
separation away from directly presenting
to the immune system the advantages of
our vaccine
it's an old established technology that
we know can make a vaccine darnay and
DNA vaccines they've never led to the
licensure of a vaccine before the
advantage of the RNA and DNA approach is
you can make them pretty quickly and
accelerate the timeframe most Kovach 19
vaccine development started back in
early January when Chinese scientists
first shared the genetic sequence for
this new virus with scientists around
the world we were working on a seasonal
influenza vaccine based on mRNA when the
pandemic came upon us fast and furiously
when the Chinese made the sequence
available of SAS Kobe to our partners at
biotechs
they took the sequence and immediately
started to make Kovach 19 specific mRNA
constructs we were able to design
vaccine sequence in three hours by
applying the known DNA sequence of the
virus which was available from China
leveraging what we know of the corona
viruses and what targets are appropriate
as a vaccine targets we were able to
hone in and extract out the DNA sequence
for the spike protein and then turn that
sequence into a very well optimised
vaccine sequence both of these nucleic
acid vaccine companies built their
vaccines from scratch once they
downloaded the genetic sequence for this
new virus doctor Hotez this team had a
different reaction when they saw the
genetic sequence I'll never forget it
when they put their data up on bio
archive and I don't let it said holy
crap we may have a vaccine that could
cross protect we've been working on
corona virus vaccines since 2011 for
nine years the team baylor college
realized that they might have a vaccine
in their freezer that would work against
this new corona virus
alena my science co-partner had the
vision to keep it on stability protocol
meaning that in case people did get
interested in it when you put our
vaccine on stability is take it out of
the freezer every six months and
confirmed that it hasn't been corrupted
or degraded what we had was we had the
genetic code of the virus and most
importantly since we were focused and a
component of that spiked protein called
the receptor binding domain you know if
you look at a picture of covin 19 it
looks like a doughnut for the piece of
RNA stuffed inside and then emanating
out of the done though those spikes and
the rounded ends of those spikes as the
receptor binding domain that docks with
the receptor and we saw that there was
quite a bit of similarity was not a
perfect match but close enough that we
thought that our vaccine could cross
protect vaccine research begins with
preclinical trials on animals what
animals have you been testing your
vaccine in we've been testing our
vaccines and two types of mice one is
genetically modified mice that makes the
human h2 receptor the other are mice
that are infected with mouse adapted
virus vaccine candidates starts and mice
because they're you know very easy to
deal with mice are easy to come by
you can test many many different
constructs in a mouse it's a pre screen
and so a lot of constructs went into
mice for came up on top
they gave good responses t-cell
responses expected t-cell humoral b-cell
responses to make antibody and the
innate responses
so typically preclinical trials take
years as we heard from dr. HOTAS but
right now these companies are getting
through preclinical trials remarkably
fast and how is it that you were able to
start preclinical development on day one
we just did it faster and in parallel we
started the mouse testing same time as
the guinea pigs almost the same time as
the rabbits almost the same time as the
non-human primates
these are usually done in a serial steps
we just did everything
arolea everything happens in parallel
but we are in a very unique situation
right now in such an emergency the
question was can we make a decision in a
mouse across those four constructs and
the answer was no because mice ain't men
so we have to learn what would give us
the most potent vaccine concern actually
we made a decision to move this into
clinical studies this is often being
pitched as a race between vaccines I
don't see it that way I think you're
gonna probably see multiple vaccines
emerge once research has a satisfied
with the immune response that they're
seeing in preclinical testing then they
move on to human testing how far into
clinical trials are you and what's that
process been like we just started a
phase one trial again of April with the
first volunteer being dosed all 40
volunteers received their first dose so
we have developed a phase 1/2 program
that is really also a Unicom very unique
because it is what we call a seamless
trial so it starts with a small group of
individuals that will receive the four
candidates we then will make very quick
real-life decisions based on the
emerging data of which candidates will
move ahead and which candidates will be
eliminated Pfizer is doing phases one
and two of its clinical trials at the
same time and many companies are doing a
lot more in parallel than would normally
happen what all of these vaccine
scientists are looking for is the right
kind of immune response what kind of
immune response did you see with your
vaccine we were able to see very strong
robust antibody and T saw immune
responses against our vaccine antigen
the immune response that our vaccine is
inducing is actually able to prevent the
infection at least the disease
in the annals that is to induce a
response that we call an innate immune
response so that's usually immune
response that recognizes dangerous
signals like there's a virus coming in
or there's a bacterium coming in while
this is happening the RNA is also
inducing what we call adaptive immune
responses so here we get t-cell
responses those t-cells that give help
to other parts of the immune system but
also t-cells that by themselves can
recognize virally infected cells and
kill those cells to eradicate the
infection so that was also very
important and the fruit bomb is what we
call the humoral part of the immune
response so that's immune response that
produces protective antibodies so we
like the RNA because all three arms of
the immune system are triggered at the
same time can you walk me through how
your vaccine would work in somebody's
body the immune system sees these
genetically engineered antigens and
produces an antibody and the antibody
binds to the spike protein of the virus
and shuts the virus done once the
vaccine makes it through testing the
next major challenge is storage and the
stability of a vaccine can make it or
break it how does a protein vaccine
compared to RNA DNA vaccines in terms of
stability and what temperature you have
to keep at DNA vaccines and other
advantages you don't need to keep it
cold our vaccine you need to keep cold
via a plasmid is one of the most stable
biological molecules in the world we've
demonstrated our long-term storage is a
normal refrigeration temperature we can
make it set down in room temperature for
over a year with perfect stability or
vaccine candidates right now are stored
frozen the stability of RNA there's
still some work to do in order to get
the RNA into the cell
it needs to be formulated for lack of a
better
description in a little fat droplet so
there lipids involved so they surround
your name they help stabilize the RNA
and so this little fat droplet then
serves as a vehicle to be taken up by a
human cell once the vaccines made it
through clinical trials and safety
testing the next big step is scaling up
and manufacturing I think the way the
approach nationally has been to try to
get lots of vaccines accelerated into
clinical trials so you get lots of shots
on goal and then you have this
interesting phenomenon of manufacturing
at risk that's the term dr. pouchy uses
which is manufacturing these vaccines in
scale even though you don't know it's
gonna work or if it's safe we've been
thinking about scaling up our
manufacturing of these vaccines from day
one you know first successful with Cove
in 1919
we need to manufacture billion doses a
year right eventually at least hundreds
of millions of doses a year so that's a
scale that we were not previously built
to handle thankfully there are a lot of
folks who have committed both from the
government levels and the NGO levels to
support the scale up we have this of
course in mind and already working on
the scale of activities to at least
produce hundreds of millions of doses
the question on everyone's mind when
will we have a vaccine if everything
goes well and if the emergency use path
is available potentially by the end of
this year I don't see a path by which
you're going to have a vaccine available
by the fall I don't see how it's
possible to collect sufficient data to
show when the vaccine works and second
that the vaccine is safe in our
situation we don't have years we don't
have months time is up we need to be
really really fast
what took years we now do in months in
my wildest dreams I would have never
imagined that this is possible this
accelerated time life the development of
a coded 19 vaccine is unprecedented we
have never seen vaccine development
happen at this rate with so many
different candidates or being tested to
fight the same virus we're seeing
cutting edge never before approved
technologies being tried and tested
alongside much more traditional methods
there are so many different kinds of
vaccines being developed right now so I
hope this brings some clarity about the
different methods that are being used
and check out my other video which
explains just how soon we might have a
vaccine thank you so much for taking
time out of your busy schedule to talk
with me thank you very much it was a
pleasure talking to y'all no problem at
all all the best bye bye
[Music]